l'état de la planète inquiète on
consomme plus qu'elle y reste sauf qu'on
est disponible j'en suis assez d'accord
c'est fou dessus on s'intéresse plus à
l'environnement
on attend que ça finisse mes forces
capitalistes sont tellement leurs forces
sont tellement d'ennemis que c'est ce
qu'on veut cette croissance nous conduit
vers l'effondrement de nos civilisations
et pourtant cette croissance économique
est plutôt vantée dans les discours
politiques
elle est signe d'une économie saine
créatrice d'emplois si l'économie va
tout va dit on mais est ce toujours vrai
[Musique]
hautes études commerciales on forme les
futurs cadres les dirigeants
d'entreprise de demain
la mission ici contribuer à l'essor de
la société à la croissance mais en plein
coeur de cette institution économique
un professeur en gestion va à
contre-courant à quoi bon parler
d'économie quand l'environnement va mal
tous les cours où on vous tente pas
d'écologie de la merde de la merde c'est
tout ça juste pas de sens on va penser
l'action humaine
indépendamment de ce qui se passe sur la
planète des effets de l'action humaine
sur la planète c'est ça se tient plus et
ça vous pour l'économie il marie abraham
de former des entrepreneurs plutôt que
des entrepreneurs
on a dépassé un certain nombre de
limites biogéochimiques planétaire on a
toutes les chances de parvenir à quelque
chose qu'on pourrait appeler un
effondrement il n'enseigne pas la
croissance mais la décroissance
soutenable et l'innovation sociale au
hcc une logique d'autoproduction c'est à
dire produire pour satisfaire nos
propres besoins c'est la mise en commun
aussi de nos ressources et dire qu'en
fait
il s'agit de remettre en question aussi
la propriété privée telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui fondamentalement la
possibilité que des humains puissent
accumuler pour leurs propres intérêts de
tel de telles richesses de telles sommes
d'argent ça devrait tout simplement plus
être possible
l'écologie est au coeur des
préoccupations des jeunes comme
alexandra ferland forcément utilisent
trop de ressources et on crie trop de
déchets dans les systèmes économiques
ont en ce moment donc la décroissance et
d'arrêter de voir toujours croître
l'intérêt est là mais à douze jours des
élections au québec
l'environnement est loin d'être la
priorité le débat de ce soir au débat
sur le climat aux hec le parti libéral
brille par son absence
on parle des réductions de gaz à effet
de serre et c'est important aussi de
fixer d'ici de même quand on n'est pas
nécessairement au gouvernement un peu
comme on le fait par exemple pour les
questions d'immigration
quand on voit que le parti quel plus de
chances de gagner l'élection provinciale
dans trois semaines et celui qui se
désintéresse le plus de ces questions ça
fait très très peur c'est une autre
raison de penser qu'on est vraiment mal
barré au bâtiment 7 à pointe saint
charles
on a compris l'urgence on applique déjà
la décroissance cet espace industriel
abri des ateliers d'artistes
une micro brasserie et une épicerie
locale marco silvestro fait partie des
militants qui ont lutté pendant 10 ans
pour récupérer ce bâtiment du cn le
projet dans lequel on est ici c'est un
projet autonomiste au sens où on veut
que les gens viennent ici faire ce
qu'ils veulent faire
on leur dit plus tôt il ya un espace de
mais ici je n'ai nous aider venez nous
aider à gérer la bâtisse et vous aurez
accès aux équipements
ici on suit de loin la campagne
électorale pour isabelle mona landriot
l'avenir est dans l'économie de partage
à l'épicerie le des tons vous pouvez
échanger trois heures par mois de votre
temps compte des rabais à l'épicerie
puis vous participez à toutes les
décisions collectif
je me rends compte que le système
capitaliste dans lequel on vit
on produit sans compter les ressources
qu'on a ça a des conséquences
désastreuses autant sur notre santé que
le tissu social que l'environnement et
je trouve que le bâtiment 7 6 par an
expirant parce que on essaye
tranquillement de faire les choses
autrement faire les choses autrement
c'est aussi le message dit marie abraham
à ses étudiants
ils ont d'ailleurs créé un jardin au
pied de l'institution on vise en fait à
créer une espèce de système autonome qui
va fonctionner un peu de lui-même il ya
un travail au départ à mettre en place
car pendant que les politiciens
tergiverse sur les questions de
l'environnement comme l'écrit voltaire
il faut cultiver notre jardin
[Musique]